be so good to see you haven't seen you
since tiff during arrival
oh my gosh good to see you and glenn
it's so nice to meet you
uh you both are absolutely amazing in
this film i'm really excited to talk
about this film because
there's a lot of emotions behind it but
for both of you to be able to see
yourself in this
type of transformation and based on a
true story
what is that like as an actor at amy
oh it's a it's a privilege when you get
an opportunity to play characters that
are written with this complexity
and you have a great team of people
working on the transformation
but also to have the family be so
available and open
and really allow us insight to
um their experiences so for me it was a
real privilege to get to
to play bev glenn
yes i agree um
you know mama obviously isn't here
anymore but she was so
loved slash feared but mostly
loved by not just her family but
neighbors and friends and
she she's kind of legendary and was
larger than life so the what i could get
from the family
which helped me tremendously was very
very specific things about the
the tone of her voice and how she walked
and stood and sat
and held her cigarettes and um you know
gesticulate
gesticulated and and they she was she's
still so
vivid in their minds it gave me a very
vivid idea of
of the the kind of um wonderful presence
of this woman who made such a difference
in their lives
and there's a pivotal moment too when jd
realized he's in control of change
i mean because of mayma that's there to
support him in a way
um what was that moment for you when you
realized you could live your dream that
passion for
to become an actor
glenn you want to take it i always like
to hear your story on this so
yeah well i always wanted to be an actor
i you know i was
hugely affected by the early disney
movies you know i'm i'm old now but they
and fairy tales so i i very much i mean
i was
grew up i've always been an introvert
i've always lived much in my head we
played and pretended my whole childhood
so it just seemed like a natural thing
to do
but you know what i just wanted to be an
actor i didn't think about being a
star or i didn't even think about movies
that's why i started in theater i
i just was fascinated and had this
really compulsion um to tell stories
through through character and i've been
incredibly blessed to do what i think
i'm here on this
particular planet to do i i you know
that's i'm
very very blessed to to be able to
fulfill my dreams oh amy yeah that was
great
i love hearing glenn talk about it
because it makes me love
being an actor even more to hear her
talk about
um getting to fulfill her dream i think
for me it was
um i was at a pivotal place where i
wanted to focus on dance but i was
really good at athletics and i knew
focusing on dance which i wasn't as good
at
would mean that i probably wouldn't be
going to college because i would not be
able to go financially so my parents
always thought that i could get a
scholarship through athletics and
i basically told them i had no interest
in athletics and i wanted to focus on
dance and the arts and
um i think i the moment that i committed
to
um sort of a life in the arts
i think that was the moment where i sort
of began to
sort of live more authentically who i
was
um so that was sort of my moment is sort
of turning away from
what my parents had wanted for me to
what i want for myself
and that's a hard thing to do you know
i really applaud that 15 year old girl
so
yeah my dad told me to learn
uh shorthand oh yeah yeah have something
to fall back on when you don't get a job
my dad was a singer so i think that he
knew that it was a hard road to walk
you know oh yeah what
you know this story kind of resonates in
2020 when you watch it you're kind of
thinking about how is life in america
right now
what do you want viewers to get out of
this film at a time like this
glenn
empathy empathy for people
whose lives are different from ours and
uh whose challenges and
uh are are might be different from ours
um but
also to realize where our common
humanity is and to focus on that
and and just finally i know i can't
really talk about the oscars right now
but there's so much buzz about both of
you and your characters
wouldn't it be nice for both of you to
win together
yes but as long as you can sit together
together and laugh together
it would be wonderful i would like to
wear pajamas together
i would like to lose and for glenn to
win
so that then i could be tied with her
[Music]
you know they're going to will me out in
a wheelchair when i'm like 90.
so here you are
[Laughter]
please your bottle of work is so
beautiful
anyway thank you so much to both of you
congratulations on the film truly you
guys are both
absolutely amazing at it so thank you
thank you